Oh
[Music]
landed it just took off
look I'm doing it right
it got the hose don't touch it I might
come along maybe he didn't hear it like
are you kidding me
okay I assumed was gonna hover you
imagine if that just went was your
window listen it could have went through
your good have went through my window
normally my failsafe is you take your
hands off of the controls and it just
hovers in place baby Bullard was like
mama I like I just
I just bought it so from my few second
flight test I will say it is fairly
responsive but I took my hands off of
the joysticks and it continued to go
sideways and that's where we really yeah
[Music]
oh my god
oh my god it's terrible
alright you know what
oh I'm sorry it's not funny no I'm just
so upset like I was not touching
anything this is gonna be your official
review
I gotta get new blades and they only
give you two as replacements I'd like to
show you guys something so we're
preparing for the Halloween party I'd
like to show you my spooky setting are
you ready for this no I prefer you're
gonna get so spooked we'll start with
this color a nice one
wait this is not what I wanted